It was on christmas eve day December 24th
during Columbus’s first voyage to the Americas
that one of his ships the Santa Maria drifted
onto a bank due to the fact that the helmsman
thinking the seas were calm enough, gave the
control of the tiller to one of his young
subordinates.
This had proven to be a huge mistake as the
boy managed the run the boat across some shallow
waters where it got permanently stuck and
damaged.
This happened to occur off the coast of today’s
northern Haiti and so the expedition decided
to to go ashore and seek help from the local
Arawak people who where a subgroup of the
brother Taino people which inhabited the Caribbean.
They soon came in to contact with the ruler
of the Marien Chiefdom, Guacanagari.
He wasn’t the only chief in Hispaniola as
the island was divided in to 5 chiefdoms,
however he was the only one who mattered to
the Europeans at the moment.
After talking to Guacanagari, as Columbus’s
son recalls, the chief and the people were
extraordinarily nice.
More than happy to help out giving the Spaniards
large canoes, storage houses and man power
to salvage and store whatever they could get
from the immobile ship.
Afterwards Guacanagari along with multiple
traders from the surrounding tribes meat with
Columbus himself.
During the conversation the traders enthusiastically
traded all their gold for the Spaniards eagle
bells as they were fascinated with the sound
they made.
After seeing the amount of gold that the local
people possessed and the promise of Guacanagari
to get more from the Cibao mountains located
in today's Dominican Republic, Columbus decided
that the imobel Santa Maria and it’s saved
cargo be dismantled and use for construction
of a colony where he will leave the men which
are most important in setting up such colony
i.e. carpenters, physicians, taylors etc.
in total 36 men were left behind.
This colony which was named La Navidad was
to wait for Columbus’s return all while
gathering information on the New World and
trading with the local natives largely for
gold.
Before Columbus’s departure Guacanagari
assured Columbus that if anything were to
happen to his men he will help out the Christian
colony in any way he can.
Columbus thanked Guacanagari and also ordered
his man that if anything ill faded where to
acure that they drop all their gold into the
constructed wooden fortress’s well as to
be found by Columbus when he returns.
Now with the first ever European colony established
in the New World columbus set sail back to
Europe.
A year later in 1493 Columbus returned from
Spain to the town of La Navidad where upon
entering the town harbor found the entire
colony burned down with no gold and no survivors.
Confused and horrified by the site Columbus
ordered his men to check for bodies and look
in the fortress’s well for the missing gold.
There was no gold in the well but several
dead bodies of the colonists were found in
a nearby field.
This however still did not explain what happened
to the entire colony.
Then suddenly the brother of Guacanagari accompanied
by several other natives appeared and wished
to speak to Columbus.
Upon hearing his story it all became clear.
After Columbus's departure the men of the
La Navidad quickly started to mingle with
the local women living with 4 or 6 woman at
once, Most of them also started to hord larger
and larger stashes of gold oftentimes bartering
for gold behind each others backs.
Soon the competition between getting more
women and more gold turn into frequent arguments
and It became so bad that some of the colonists
started to kill each other.
With all this chaos and hostility in the colony
some of the spaniards decided to leave for
the mountains where they heard the golden
mines where located.
They most likely entered the neighboring chiefdom
of Magua which angered the local ruler killing
all of the Spaniards that dared to come for
his gold.
Outraged by the actions of the colonists the
ruler organized a full on military attack
on La Navidad to get rid of the remaining
Europeans.
When the attack came, La Navidad was defended
by only 11 men with everyone else either dead
or fleeing with all their gold and wives to
other tribes perhaps even on a different islands.
However the 11 Spaniards weren’t alone because
Guacanagari honored his promise to Columbus
and with his men joined in the defence of
the colony.
But they were still extremely outnumbered
and after a some fearsome fighting the colony
just got overwhelmed by the sheer number of
attackers.
All remaining europeans along with some of
Guacanagari’s men were slaughtered and the
entire colony got set on fire.
Guacanagari himself managed to escape but
was injured and that is why his brother came
to visit Columbus as Guacanagari was unable
due to his injuries.
Columbus uphold by his men's actions later
thanked Guacanagari personally for honoring
his promise after which the two exchange gifts
and Columbus went on to try to settle other
areas of Hispaniola.
And so goes the disasters story of the First
ever European colony in the New World.
(if we’re not counting the vikings)
This video was brought to you by no one, Because
I am too small to get a sponsor.
Actually no scratch that, this video was brought
to you by coffee, lots coffee.
And tea, and also actually photoshop, computers,
late nights, but whatever basically this video
wasn’t brought to you by money because I
can’t even monetize my videos.
Actually again scratch all of what I said.
This video and all the videos I made in the
past 8 months were brought to you by Narbris
for one dollar each.
What a hack of a deal..